given the triangle below use the
Pythagorean theorem to find the length
of the missing side X and the missing
side X here you see it's the side
opposite the 90-degree angle this is the
longest side of the nut of this right
triangle and it is which is also called
the hypotenuse called the hypotenuse and
the Pythagorean theorem tells us that
the sum of the squares of the shorter
sides is equal to the square of the
hypotenuse so in this case it would be 8
squared plus 15 squared 15 squared the
sum of the squares of the shorter side
shorter sides I should say is going to
be equal to the hypotenuse squared and
so 8 squared is 64 15 squared is 225
that needs to be equal to x squared and
then 64 plus 225 is what that's 289 is
equal to x squared or X is equal to the
principal square root of 289 and you may
or may not already know this but this is
17 times 17 or 17 squared so X is equal
to X is equal to 17 and we are done and
maybe the hardest part is recognizing
that 289 is a perfect square it is the
square it is 17 times 17 but if you
didn't realize that you could try out
some numbers or worse case have to use
the calculator but this is but that's
it's a good one to recognize